maub zi joins us here in studio now he's
a professor of Middle East politics at
katar University good to have you with
us on the program Maj Israel is at War
that's what uh Netanyahu says the clouds
gathering it seems for a very long
protect prot protracted operation MH I
mean what happened in the last few hours
absolutely um is gamechanging game
changing onto the politics of the region
I think the region will be different
post 7th of October
2023 um for the first time nonstate
actor resistant movement decided to um
react U against the cire and and make
all of this in a few hours and achieve a
lot in term of militarily um and also
the major thing the major thing is is is
the image and the The Narrative have
they have created so far I think the
Israeli side is in facing a real
challenge on tackling the image and that
has been created in the last few hours
and also the narrative created by um
Hamas I think this also complicated uh
the role and the reaction of different
player whether Regional player or
International Players maup stay with us
because we also have another guest
joining us uh from Tel Aviv Rafael
jusami is joining us as a Former
Intelligence officer as well for the
Israeli uh Army good to have you with us
uh uh on the program as well youve just
been listening to what our uh academic
here has been saying can I just get your
initial reaction about the challenges
that are faced now by the Israeli
Defense Forces when it comes to the
operation that's been led by Palestinian
factions fighting from
Gaza well first of all uh I want to feel
sad for both the Palestinian people and
the Israeli people because yet another
round of violence has started in the
region uh of late lots thousands and
thousands of gazan workers had permits
to work in Israel thousands and
thousands of Palestinians from the West
Bank had permits to work in Israel and
things were looking a bit better with a
possible normalization with Saudi Arabia
and all of a sudden
unfortunately uh we were taken by
surprise absolute surprise so the Hamas
of course is now a triumphant because
they manag uh to put up this operation
an operation who for so far has only
made civilian casualties and now we are
at War unfortunately this time as
opposed to different round that opposed
Gaza to Israel this time it's a
full-fledged War meaning that this time
the answer of the IDF of the isra
Israeli forces and government will be
much more prolonged mused and violent
and it's regretful because because of
the amount of casualties this morning uh
the IDF and Israeli government have no
choice but to retaliate but maybe this
time I think the countdown of the life
of the Hamas has started I think by this
time it is a necessity to anate the
Hamas well let me just bring you in
there let me just let me just get in
there because we I understand your
position and your point of view in terms
of uh what you think will happen to
Hamas but at the end of the day we need
to know what uh the IDF uh will be
instructed to do considering they've
taken heavy losses already and it hasn't
just been civilians it has been military
uh Personnel that's been cooperated by
our Witnesses on the ground uh in this
attack so therefore we are waiting to
hear from the Prime Minister and the
cabinet as to how they will react and
which dare I say units or uh areas of
the military command will be the ones
that will have to head Hamas off at the
border with Gaza I mean what would your
understanding be of the military
operation or the conversation that has
to be had in the Israeli cabinet right
now about how the IDF proceeds from
here okay so on the ground the first uh
emergency
is to take care of these Villages
Israeli villages on the border with Gaza
that have been invested by Hamas
terrorists uh this Hamas operatives have
managed to destroy the houses maybe to
take hostages so the first priority now
for the Israeli Security Services is to
try and eliminate these terorist and try
to free the hostages alive that's the
absolute first priority the second part
of the plan has already started it's the
usual uh attack by air and artillery uh
aiming at Islamic Jihad and Hamas
targets inside Gaza uh mostly military
targets with also a preparation for a
multif front possibility of War meaning
that maybe southern Lebanon with theah
but also with Hamas presence because we
must remember that the Hamas and other
Palestinians in factions do have
operatives in South Lebanon in the
refugee camps we also have the
possibility of the West Bank arising um
into a kind of antifa so all these
scenarios have to be taken into account
by the IDF and that's why uh we call it
a war already it has a name the the name
is called the swords of iron and that's
why also there is a massive I can say
massive because we're speaking of tens
of thousands of Reserve soldiers and
officers being called into immediate
action and very high ranking officers
have been already delegated to the south
of Israel okay to manage the situation
so there is an an allowed War the
political level will have to decide up
to what stage they wish to escalate do
they want to enter Gaza for instance
will there be
terrestrial invasion of Gaza by the
Israeli troops or we will just attack
from far will there be Commando
operations one of them could be
attacking Gaza City and circling the
hospital of Gaza City to go under it
where I hiding there's the bunker of the
leaders of the Hamas is under the
hospital of Gaza City so there could be
an operation to destroy that there are
going to be many many actions led
because the public opinion in Israel
being fed up with what is happening will
demand from the governor to be acting
strongly even if it will be costing us
lives we know that we will lose many
lives during that battle uh this is The
Price to Pay to Win It Well we shall see
what does happen in the coming hours I'm
sure we'll be coming back to you again
as well Rafael jusami thanks for joining
us from Tel Aviv let's come back to maub
sahi here in the studio you were
listening to some of what Mr jerus had
to say nodding in Parts disagreeing in
in in other areas let's just start again
now with armed assault uh by the
Palestinians by Hamas into um Israel we
have to get for our International views
make them understand that Hamas is not a
conventional Army absolutely it is an
armed group yes and doesn't act in the
same way that an army from a sovereign
state absolutely absolutely why is that
an advantage or a disadvantage to Hamas
and why should Israel be so worried
about this no we need to to remember and
remind the viewers that Gaza is under
occupation Gazza despite the fact
Israelis has been withdraw from Gaza but
Gaza is still under uh I would say um
occupation because Israel is controlling
everything comes toaza so so basically
we cannot ignore that fact number two um
Hamas is is acting as as a as a as a
faction which basically running Gaza
politically and in term of safety and
economic uh uh factors so basically they
are uh managing Gazza from all all
aspects so this action this morning is
is done based on the fact that they are
under occupation their life is is
difficult Israelis has um attacked many
many many times they are disrespecting
the uh uh holy places uh they undermine
the Palestinian rights whether in West
Bank or on Gaza so it was it was a it
was an operation to send multi messages
to Israel to International Community and
to those who believe that building peace
with Arab peace with Arab worlds is a
priority to fix the internal situation
which is the put people under
occupation M of course will we continue
to speak to you throughout the day for
the moment thanks very much